hi there today we're looking at
deconstructing lottery tickets zeroes
signs and the Super mask by Hari Joe
John Islam
Roseanne Lou and Jason Osinski of Boober
ai so this is a follow up paper to the
original paper that was called the
lottery ticket hypothesis I have done a
video on that paper so if you don't know
what the lottery ticket hypothesis is I
suggest you go watch it just very
quickly very quickly the laundry ticket
hypothesis states the following if you
have a neural network that has let's say
it has these layers and has some weights
the lottery ticket hypothesis states
that there are a subset of weights that
are significantly less number of weights
than India rigged in them
in the original network a sub set of
weights are already enough to be for
this network to be trained in a
successful fashion so there are sub
networks here if you train them you will
get the same or even higher accuracy
than if you train the full network now
this the intrinsic part here is that the
sub network must be initialized at the
same place as the full network and so
with that goes the lottery ticket
algorithm the lottery ticket algorithm
is the following first train the full
network right second select the largest
weights select the largest weights at
the end of the training and then third
reset the weights to their initial value
and this needs to be the same initial
value at which you initialize them at
step one and then terrain so once you
have the desired weights these ones
right you need to reset them to their
original
value before training and then you can
retrain just the small subnetwork and
that will work the same or better than
the original network so it's basically a
pruning technique so this is the lottery
ticket hypothesis the fact that there
are these sub networks or the
proposition and the lottery ticket
algorithm is the process by which you
obtain the these so-called winning
tickets right again the the full-wave
video will make this clearer all right
so this paper is going to shine some
light on different aspects of these
winning tickets and what is really
important and what isn't
and how you can obtain even better ones
right so they often show the following
2d plots here and these 2d plots will
spend like a little time understanding
them there is two dimensions here and
each one of these plots is represent a
single weight in the neural network so a
single weight is just one floating-point
number right on the x-axis you have WI
which is the initial value of the weight
now this is randomly initialized right
so here's 0 and you randomly initialize
these these weights in the neural
networks so this number is random the
WUF is on the y axis and that is the
final value of the weight this here this
is after training right this is trained
so the if a point is for example here
that means it had this like a 3d value
of 3 before training and then after
training it went to a value of 1 right
so it got initialized at 3 and as GD
thought now it's better at 1 why so so
you see that there's an ellipsis here
why is there an ellipsis that's because
very often the initial and the final
weight
you are positively correlated so even if
a weight initially is positive it tends
to also be positive at final and that's
just because of the nature of SGD it
just takes little steps and basically
tries to do as little effort as possible
in order to reach its goal right it
always just goes downhill in a greedy
fashion and that means probably it it
will if it can it will elect to not move
the weights too far from their initial
position or the position of the previous
step so that's why they're correlated
and that's why you have a ellipses but
they don't have to be that's just the
authors superimposing their kind of view
so then they say what happens during the
these lottery tickets pruning is in the
original algorithm right you had the
following pruning technique you would
select all the weights that at the end
of the training had a certain magnitude
or higher and that's this year so at on
the y axis which is the final weight you
define a threshold here and everything
that is smaller magnitude than the
threshold you mask to zero right you
prune away you don't want to retain but
everything that is above that either
positively or negatively you mask to one
which means that you retain it in the
winning ticket all right so the light
regions here will be the regions where
you set the way to zero or you mask it
zero and the dark regions will be the
weights that you retain so if a weight
was initially here but then it traveled
to here during the training then sorry
of course
initially but if the y-axis is the
process during training and will
visualize this here then we'll say
initially it was
here right initially it was here and
then in subsequent steps it traveled
over this line then we would retain it
because this final value was higher than
the threshold all right so this paper
generalizes the lottery ticket algorithm
it states it in a bit of a convoluted
way but just to go quickly over it it
says first initialize a mask to all ones
randomly initialize the parameters of
the network like this now to convert
with the mask here is a bit superfluous
because just it's all ones but they do
it for consistency and they say train
the parameters of the network to
completion do you know the initial
weights before training by WI that's
what we saw on the plot and the final
weights by W F then here is the first
generalization use the mask criterion n
to produce a masking score for each
currently unmasked weight rank the
weights in each layer by their scores
set the mask value for the top P percent
to one at the bottom 100 minus P percent
to zero so this this masking criterion
here is now how you select the weights
to be in the winning ticket basically so
you select how the you select the
weights that you want to be part of that
trainable sub network in the original
lottery ticket algorithm this was simply
the absolute value as you can see here
then they say there is a mask one action
and a mask zero action which is
describing what happens to the weights
that were part that are part of the
winning ticket and what happens to the
weights that aren't part of the winning
ticket now to the second one first the
ticket in the original algorithm they
were just pruned right set to zero and
frozen during any subsequent training
that's what we looked at before but you
can think of different things like
setting them to a constant value and
just
not training them the common thing is
that they are masked to zero so they
will not be trained but you can still
kind of retain them at like a constant
value or a random value something like
this and same for the mask one all it
means here is that they will be trained
in the original algorithm these weights
were reset to their initial values and
marked for training in the next round
but you can think of different things
right so these this paper will
experiment with all of these with these
three steps basically step two step
three and step four and decide on what's
important and what isn't
so the first they go with the mask
criteria this is the criteria how do we
select which weights we should retain
and which ones we should
so we're think of it we have our full
network we have trained it to completion
right and for each weight we know its
initial and its final value and based on
that we now need to make a decision
should this particular weight be
included in the winning ticket or
shouldn't it the original paper as we
said simply took the absolute value of
the final weight completely ignoring the
original weight right so they do
experiment with different things first
and you can see this in the pot here
large final is what we had and we saw
this small final yes this score here
which is just retain the weights that
have a small final value see the Y
threshold is stays the same but it is
inverted we retain the weights that are
inside of the threshold this is this is
a control criterion right just to kind
of do the opposite of what the initial
paper that large in it ignores the final
value and simply goes on the daily
initial value of the of the weight right
as you can see here now the threshold is
on the x-axis and the same for small in
it the control case for that
then there is a large in it large final
where you say okay I only retain a
weight if it both was large at
initialization and large in the final
value so it's an additional criterion to
the original paper now of course these
are ranking scores so you're you won't
actually have the same threshold you
will simply make the thresholds lower
and then that region up here that you
retain will become larger to reach the
same percentage of weights retained so
that's something you have to keep in
mind the control case small in its small
final then the interesting case here
magnitude increase which means all
everywhere where the final weight is
larger than the initial weight or the
ranking score is basically based on how
much you move and this depicted here if
so if a weight was originally here it
just needs to be larger it just needs to
be above that so basically it needs to
be above the diagonal here right the
diagonal are basically weights that are
as high in the final terrain version as
they were at initialization and
everything above this here or of course
below this here so you need to think of
a second one here and then everything in
this region and in this region magnitude
wise will fulfill that criterion and
then movement simply describes how far
they move now this this is the same as
the magnitude increase but just the they
don't do the absolute values before they
subtract so it's basically everything
above this diagonal so you don't look at
how much the magnitude increase but if a
weight goes from very much negative to
just a little positive this will already
qualify because
moved a very far away and then random
you simply mask at random this is a
control case so our focus is going to be
on the following the large final which
is the original right the large in it
might be interesting the large in it
large final at interesting and the
magnitude increase might be interesting
now what do they find we'll go to the
plot with the most effects the star here
is simply a significance indicator so
disregard the stars for now the
magnitude increase tends to perform the
best as you can see magnitude increase
and compare that to large final large
final is the original algorithm
magnitude increased tends to perform
better than the large final but
interestingly but if you look across the
experiments it doesn't tend to do that
consistently or often and there are
these effects here when you go to really
small networks doesn't and these stars I
said disregard them they are significant
indicators for a t-test
but the t-test is just across five
samples and what you're seeing here is
not a standard deviation but the min and
Max overly five runs so I see there
might be an effect here but I'm
absolutely not trusting the this the
these the claim here that this is
significant because it's just in one
plot in one network on one data set and
yeah so if you want to make the claim
that the magnitude increase works better
than the large final may be what you can
say for sure is that for that things
like large in it they they don't work we
we don't really
here interestingly large innit large
final doesn't work as well as you can
see here it kind of goes below these I
just think that's what I said you by
imposing two thresholds each of them
needs to be lower than the original
threshold right so now it's not really
the fact that it's large innit large
final but it's the fact that the large
finals have a lower threshold then the
the ones that are only threshold in a
large final and therefore it's just an
additional irrelevant criterion yeah so
those are those are the results but
basically you can see that it really
tends to be in my opinion that means it
tends to be a good criterion to select
the large final weights and I don't
trust this magnitude increase thing too
much I think it pretty much measures the
same thing as the large final and I
don't really see that it outperforms all
right then they go over the mask one
actions and the mask one actions
remember these are how should we treat
the weights that we have selected to be
in the winning ticket now we can do the
following things we can re in it which
basically means we set them back to the
beginning of the optimization procedure
that is what the original algorithm does
we can reshuffle which means that we get
all the weights that we got from the
that better mask to one and we just
shuffle them around right that
guarantees us that the same weight
distribution is still followed but it's
not that each way it is at the original
weight so this if this performs well it
could just mean that it is about the
distribution of initial weights and not
exact configuration and then constant
it just means we'll set them to some
constant okay so either either we set
them to a negative or a positive
constant and then the weights that our
mask to zero will become a zero so here
are the results as you can see there are
a bunch of things performing about at
the same level which are the red orange
and blue curves here the blue curve is
rewind with large final now that is your
original algorithm the orange is
reshuffle in it sign and the red is
constant in it sign now what does init
sign mean you see that these these
things will perform well if they have
this init sign a set of RAM sign now R
and sign means a random sign which
basically means we reshuffle or we
initialize to the constant with v like
the constant will be 50/50 whether it's
plus or minus alpha and the reshuffle
will mean we don't care how we shuffle
the weights as long as you know we
shuffled the same weight somehow within
its sign what they mean is that they
make sure that the sign of the the sign
of the weight that is reinitialized
is equal to the sine of the weight in
the final that in the in the final train
network so they're basically saying that
this weight is positive in the winning
ticket
so we should initialize them to a
positive thing that to a positive sign
so that means that all the that means
that all the other
alfe in this case here it is going to be
a plus alpha if the original weight was
Paul
if weight and a negative alpha the
original weight was a negative weight
and also here that shuffling will only
happen between the positive and the
negative weights right now this might
actually be at initial nor that final
but they are extremely correlated so
that shouldn't be a big difference
so these perform all about at the same
level which again is interesting right
so that the authors here claim oh it's
just about the sign so that the
important part here seems to be designed
I disagree with that I think what's
happening here is if you do these things
what you'll do is you'll automatically
be closer let's actually give the
benefit of the doubt here and you say
this is the initial what you'll do is if
you do plus alpha only if the initial
weight was positive they will be closer
together right those two things are
closer together than a random plus or
minus alpha an expectation they will be
close together and also with the
reshuffle basically what with this init
sign thing what you ensure is that
you're your initialization is closer to
this one here so it will be more like
the large final initialization where you
rewind the weights and I don't think you
can make the claim it's just about the
sign I would guess that any algorithm
that makes the way it's closer to this
original lottery ticket thing will also
perform well what is true and that's
what the authors say is that the so
called like the basin of Attraction
seems to be much larger than you have to
exactly hit the original weights but I
think this effect here is not at all
about the sign and just about the fact
that you make them closer by matching
the sign
you already make them closer and
expectation and that's why it might work
also stop stop testing it point zero
zero five significance level with five
runs that's no all right so the last
thing they do is the mask zero actions
basically how do we treat the weights
that we want to get rid of that are not
part of the trainable winning ticket all
right so they experiment with different
things they say okay here is the
original Network it's at a certain it's
at a certain accuracy right these are
the black lines and then the blue lines
are set the masks zero weights to zero
so forget about them don't include them
which is what the original algorithm did
right so that's why I see this plot
right here and these are the blue lines
and as you can saw it see in the
original paper this outperforms the
original network at first and as you
prune more and more and more here you
just have whatever 1.2 percent of the
weights then it finally gets worse now
you can do original sorry different
actions one of them is set them to their
initial values right and here they they
try to elude that by the numbers they
put here so the this thing here means
whatever you don't mask put it to the
initial value which is this I plus and
this means set everything else to zero
now this thing here means set it to
visit to the initial ID and also set
this to the initial value so set
everything to the initial value just
don't train the ones that you that you
mask right so now you end up with a
network where some of the connections
are simply frozen at their original
value and that as you can see performs
worse often it so it's below the
especially here you can see it's below
the original algorithm where you set it
to 0 this is variant
thing I think because um and I think
that's just because you you introduce
some there is some noise signal in there
so you introduce some unnecessary signal
and the author's here claim well these
weights will you mask them because they
were small in magnitude right so the
optimal value for those weights ten
seems to be close to zero so by setting
them to zero the original algorri
lottery ticket algorithm basically
freezes them at their optimal position
and if you freeze them to any other
position right away from zero then that
means the that means the you you have a
less optimal configuration here and I
can I can believe that I can follow that
not fully convinced but I can follow so
they they come up with a cool experiment
what I think is that they they say for
all the weights that we mask we're going
to set the ones below this line to zero
and the ones above them to their initial
value basically if a weight during
training moved so a weight is let's say
this is the magnitude and this is now
the training steps if a weight started
out here and during training moved up in
magnitude but it's still it's still
below the masking threshold right the
masking threshold is here so it's not
including the ticket but it moved up
we'll set it to its initial value but if
it moved down so it's lower then we'll
set it to zero right so you have the an
additional threshold of how it moved
during training that's the line here you
can see this here and that often
performs better than the original ticket
algorithm not much and it mainly tends
to be in there in the regions where you
really have low weights
then you come up with a further variant
where they also do the same thing to the
trainable weights
so these trainable weights appear they
do the same thing where they say ok
we're going to set the ones that
actually move down to during training
now these are going to be very few ones
but some of them are going to move down
during training but they don't don't go
below the threshold we're going to set
the ones to zero those ones because they
were too high initially and that
performs even better sometimes right and
again I don't I don't see this as a an
algorithm where it's set to zero or set
I it's simply because you were again
setting something closer to its optimal
value during training if if a weight
that is trainable during training sorry
went down a bit that means that its
optimal value is lower than it
originally was and it can just be that
by setting it to zero
you were actually you're doing it sorry
by setting it to zero you end up at a
point that is closer in magnitude sorry
to the optimal value then at the initial
point so I think my comment here is that
a lot of these things I think are a bit
over interpreted by the authors and
ultimately it's a it's just about
getting the weights close to where they
where their optimal value is either at
the beginning or at the end of the
training and I think the original
lottery ticket paper already did a good
job analyzing that right the last
section here they call super masks and
now super masks are is is is a thing
where they say hey if we have a mask
can't we just apply this to the or
untrained network and how will the
network perform when we do that now if
you simply take a network with random
weights on let's say on n list you have
a 10% chance because there are 10
classes right so we'll perform at 10%
accuracy if you randomly mask a bunch of
weights then again you'll stay at 10%
but if you apply the mask the large
final mask you will already get some
accuracy really interesting so without
training just by applying the mask
you'll get some accuracy and again we
can interpret this by simply the fact
the masking action it will mask weights
that are not part of the winning ticket
it will retain weights that are part of
the winning ticket weights 10 to not
move that much by SGD so basically the
mask Network is 8 a closer at a place
closer to its optimal value than the
unmasked Network and therefore it will
perform better right so I think their
findings are fairly easy to interpret
here and the last thing they do is they
say can we optimize these masks can we
train the masks now rather than
basically just training the network full
determining the mask from there can we
now take that mask and further optimize
it and they do basically a they optimize
this mask by SGD of course you have to
make it continuous during training to do
that but what you end up with is a
binary mask and they say here that it
works better than the original mask so
interestingly interestingly the if you
apply the mask of the lottery ticket
just at the beginning of training
without training the network you can see
here that it already reaches whatever 40
percent accuracy on em nest and it also
reaches non-negligible accuracy on c4 10
so 20 percent if you do a special thing
where you also look see that the sign
agrees so if the final and the original
weight have the same sign then you get a
much higher performance in this again
this is the untrained Network and they
also do this at constant values for the
same sign so the same as we saw before
and the gamut they make this big deal
about the sign here I I really think
this is just because you're closer to
the optimum when you do when you match
the sign but that that's just my opinion
and then if they train the mask they get
even higher so you see here you get even
higher performance and this is the top
is on em nest and the bottom is on C 410
so if you train the mask if you if you
just apply the mask you get non-random
performance better than random if you
look that the mask also agrees with the
signs so that you have a sign criterium
where you say I'm only going to take the
initial weights into the mask if they
have the same sign as the end weights
then you get a better performing so
initial subnetwork and if you train the
mask again you've never trained the
weights you just train the mask you can
get an even better performance and I
mean that's somewhat not surprising
because now you train the mask and yeah
so I don't think that's too surprising
but what you can see here is that the
effect on em list is appears to be very
high between these two and the effect on
C 4/10 seems to be different it seems to
be
low between these turns and high between
these two so I I wonder if there is a
big dependence on the actual task here
they also eat reduce this dynamic weight
rescaling which is basically a a kind of
a rescaling trick and then they put the
following table so here you have the
different networks and here you have the
original trained weights the performance
they reach on the task and here you have
the performance that they reach after
learned masks and dynamic weight
rescaling and you can see here that the
amnesty v'n outperforms the original
trained weight simply by learning the
mask now you can also see that on C 410
this effect is not present and I've
already seen a paper that states that on
like resonance and image net the lottery
ticket hypothesis isn't really
measurable so I want to pose another
hypothesis here and the hypothesis is
the following that you may find these
winning tickets that are performing well
at initialization or being trained well
if the task is sufficiently easy and
easier the task the more you can
basically do with it and you can already
basically eminence is so easy that you
simply have to mask out some of the
initial weights and you will already
perform extremely well where C 410 is
harder imagenet is harder again and I
believe as the tasks get harder and
harder these methods will work less and
less to the point where they don't work
anymore right that's my opinion
so basically my opinion is it appears to
be very much about how close you are to
some kind of initial lauter to some kind
of optimal lottery ticket and I think
the experiments here are very cool are
very very well designed
but I think they're often a bit
over-interpreted all right that was it
for me I invite you to check out the
paper and bye bye